quand ils prennent la route des vacances
en voiture les français vérifie les sens
lui les l'ère des pneus ils ont
cependant tendance à négliger un autre
corps simple l'opa pour leur voiture non
pour leurs passagers en particulier pour
les enfants et les nourrissons
chaque année en effet des dizaines de
départs en vacances se terminent dans
des services de réanimation hospitalier
plus ou moins dramatiquement tout
simplement parce que les acharnés de la
moyenne
oubli de s'arrêter pour donner à boire
aux enfants l'eau constitue 80% du poids
du corps d'un nouveau-né et dès que cet
enfant perd 5 % de son poids corporel il
peut commencer à éprouver des troubles
graves et qui des troubles qui peuvent
évoluer jusqu'au coma il existe des
règles simples pour éviter que de tels
accidents surviennent
la première de ces règles est évidente
c'est de ne pas laisser un enfant
enfermé dans une voiture pendant que
l'on fait les courses il peut faire plus
de 50 degrés dans une voiture lorsque la
température extérieure n'est que de 25
ou 30 degrés seulement et cette
température à l'intérieur de la voiture
sera d'autant plus élevé que la voiture
est de couleur sombre et puis la
deuxième règle élémentaire elle aussi
c'est de s'arrêter de s'arrêter 90
minutes où tous les 100 kilomètres afin
de faire boire l'enfant il s'agit pas de
ralentir simplement il faut s'arrêter
dans un endroit dans un endroit ombragé
et donner à l'enfant à boire de l'eau
suffisamment pour qu'il puisse retrouver
son calme
et puis faites en de même buvez vous
aussi vous aussi vous transpirez vous
perdez de l'eau vous perdez du sel et
toutes ces pertes peuvent retentir sur
votre conduite et sur votre fatigue des
mesures qui sont simples qu'on oublie
pourtant le plus souvent et qui vous
permette d'arriver à bon port sans que
vos vacances
elle ne tombe à l'eau